the very real Royal Rift the east coast
is bracing for Prince William and Kate's
first trip to the U.S in eight years so
could we see a Fab Four reunion with New
York city-bound Harry and Megan
we're brothers we will always be
brothers and we're certainly on
different paths at the moment tomorrow
The Prince and Princess of Wales are
heading to Boston for what's be
what's it does not include a reunion
with Prince Harry and Megan instead
during their three-day stay the future
king and queen will potentially be
rubbing elbows with celebs like Billy
eilish and Rami Malek at the second
annual earthshot prize Awards a
celebration of new ideas to solve
planets issues William simply cannot
forgive Harry not just for leaving but
for how he left before we see any sort
of repairs in this Rift between the
Brotherhood I spoke to AIDS past and
present there can be our approachment
but it is going to be some time down the
line as for Megan and Harry six days
after will and Kate hit the East Coast
they'll be in New York today Megan
dropped her final archetypes episode
tackling stereotypes and gender roles
which included her first male guest Andy
Cohen Trevor Noah and Judd Apatow this
show has featured exclusively women's
voices truth be told at the suggestion
of my husband we have to broaden the
conversation
and we have to actively include Men last
night the crown was the topic of
conversation between Dominic West and
Jimmy Kimmel your kid is on uh yeah I've
got one of my kids on yeah he plays
Prince Williams is my son yeah that's
great is that what he wants to do be an
actor no he wants to be a football
player oh all right soccer player you
know they say they've been saying that
you're too handsome to play King Charles
and I think that's true well thanks very
much no offense I came but I've had
worse yeah King Charles can relate
you've learned how to do how to do break
dance like Prince Charles yeah yeah
there's no rhythm there's no it's it's
completely a rhythmic
foreign